allez on y va
regarde un petit ça va rentrer allez on
continue
[Musique]
allez on cherche on esquive allez on
continue
allez on continue on y va allez
[Musique]
formidable
un geste bien répété fini toujours par
payer allez on continue la protection
apportée par le vaccin contre le
covid-19 diminue avec le temps
continuons la vaccination
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 à
3 semaines du coup d'envoi de la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar les critiques
continuent à fuser sur les attentes aux
droits humains de l'émirat Amnesty
International dénonce le traitement
réservé à des centaines de milliers de
travailleurs venus d'Asie sur les grands
chantiers de la Coupe du monde les ONG
demandent à la FIFA de verser 440
millions de dollars à ces ouvriers les
miRs du Qatar dénonce un acharnement
fRANCE 24 va diffuser à partir de samedi
à reporter intitulé cathares les
travailleurs de l'ombre reportaient
réalisés par Chloé demas qui viendra sur
ce plateau alors on va en parler de la
du Qatar et de cette Coupe du Monde
comment finalement en étant arrivé là
faut-il boycotter la Coupe du Monde du
Qatar le monde du sport devrait-il être
plus soucieux des droits humains dans
l'attribution d'un tournoi on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
à mes côtés Alexis de soif bonsoir vous
êtes vice-président de la FIDH avocat
également merci beaucoup
avec nous en face de vous Nabil et Nasri
bonsoir vous êtes docteur en sciences
politiques co-auteur de l'empire du
Qatar le nouveau maître du jeu et c'est
quel éditeur d'ailleurs vous l'avez près
de vous parce que j'ai vu que je l'ai
pas vu s'afficher
on le voit donc l'éditeur c'est
auto édition voilà merci d'être avec
nous également avec nous Jérôme Jérôme
Gessel bonsoir journaliste sportif
écrivain auteur du livre La face cachée
du footbusiness et ça c'est chez
Flammarion bienvenue à vous nous
rejoindra donc Chloé Chloé daumat qui
donc a fait le reportage qui va être
diffusé sur France 24 et dont on va
diffuser quelques extraits alors tout a
commencé vous le savez avec l'annonce de
l'organisation par le Qatar de la Coupe
du Monde 2022 c'était en décembre 2010 à
Zurich
depuis 12 ans le Qatar se prépare il
s'expose bien sûr à l'opinion publique
mondiale les ONG dénoncent les
conditions de travail des employés
étrangers sur les chantiers certains
politiques d'ailleurs appellent au
boycott la plupart des villes en France
Paris Lyon Lille - Marseille ou encore
Strasbourg ont décidé de ne pas diffuser
les matchs au public sur des écrans
géants l'équipe nationale australienne
de football les socceros dénonce les
conditions de travail elles appellent le
Qatar à respecter les droits des LGBTQI
dans une vidéo que vous voyez poster sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est la première
équipe participante à prendre vraiment
position le président de la FIFA Giani
Infantino lui s'est exprimé la semaine
dernière on l'écoute max
nous en sommes sûrs
nous n'avons jamais eu de plus grande
best mais ce sera la meilleure quand ils
verront l'accueil que vous réservez aux
invités dans ce pays
a dénoncé un acharnement on l'écoute
l'organisation de cette Coupe du monde
le Qatar a été la cible d'une campagne
sans précédent qu'aucun autre pays autre
n'a subi
mais il nous invite sembler clair que la
campagne persiste s'étend qu'il y a des
calomnies et du deux poids de mesure
atteignant un niveau d'acharnement qui a
amené beaucoup de gens à s'interroger
malheureusement sur les véritables
raisons et motivations de cette campagne
c'est un grand test pour un pays de la
taille du Qatar qui impressionne le
monde entier par ce qu'il a déjà
accompli et continuerait
accompliraction à vous qui représentez
donc les droits de l'homme sur ce
plateau j'ai lu que 6500 ouvriers venus
d'Inde Pakistan Népal Bangladesh Sri
Lanka sont morts pendant la construction
des stades ça en tout cas c'est selon
une enquête du gardien et selon l'OIT 50
travailleurs morts en 2020 il faut
boycotter cette coupe du monde alors
quel cynisme d'abord quand on entend le
président de la FIFA se réjouir en
disant que ce sera la plus grande coupe
du monde jamais réalisé et effectivement
il y a des violations massives des
droits humains au Qatar depuis
l'attribution en 2013 on a averti la
FIDH quand il y a eu en 2013 déjà 350
on a averti on a demandé que des mesures
soient prises et ça a continué le
rapport d'Amnesty International parle de
6500 morts mais ce n'est pas seulement
le sort des travailleurs c'est le sort
des sur des droits humains c'est le sort
le droit des femmes LGBTQ il a plus qui
sont discriminés qui sont emprisonnés
l'homosexualité qui est criminalisée
hier d'ailleurs et alors justement le
sport qui devrait être l'occasion de
rassembler de fédérer là on attribue
avec la FIFA qui vraisemblablement a été
menée à la corruption ici un état qui
est un état voyou avec l'émir du Qatar
qui est une dictature héréditaire et on
fait comme si de rien n'était à la
veille de cette coupe du monde alors le
boycott la question est beaucoup plus
vaste on aurait dû retirer avant
maintenant c'est trop tard elle aura
lieu mais comme on le voit il y a des
entreprises qui refusent d'inviter leur
gros clients et donc il y a un boycott
doux qui s'installe et qui montre que ça
ne va pas être une fête du football il y
a des banques qui refusent il y a des
sponsors qui refusent d'amener leurs
clients et donc il faut aussi demander
qu'au niveau politique il n'y ait pas de
représentation du plus haut niveau pour
faire entendre au chef d'État
qatari que on ne va pas participer à sa
fête Jérôme Gessel
j'écoute Alexis de soif avec beaucoup
d'attention mais je l'ai pas entendu moi
en 2018 quand il s'agissait de la Coupe
du monde en Russie organisé par Poutine
et là alors c'est vrai que quand les
meilleurs du Qatar mais moi j'ai pas de
j'ai pas de billes là dedans mais quand
il dit il y a deux poids de mesure c'est
à dire que le catharbaching est beaucoup
plus je dirais un pactant que ce qu'on a
connu en Russie et ce que je dois dire
aussi c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de de
fantasmes mais de manipulation même au
niveau des médias par exemple on dit il
va faire 40 degrés
à Doha c'est pas possible pour les
joueurs etc or en décembre à Doha il
fait 25 degrés température idéale pour
jouer au football après on dit attention
il y a il y a des climatisations il y a
pas besoin de climatisation quand il
fait 25 degrés alors qu'on parle
beaucoup justement on parle des droits
humains mais on parle beaucoup de
environnement aussi de vous une biologie
on est bien d'accord et on l'a dit aussi
pour la Russie mais ici on est encore un
degré plus loin il y a pas eu 6500 morts
pour la construction des stades en
Russie on va chercher on va à chaque
fois plus loin dans le cynisme et au
niveau écologique et vous le dites à
juste titre on ne comprend rien parce
qu'on va organiser les Jeux olympiques
d'hiver en Arabie Saoudite maintenant et
vous aviez un reportage juste avant dans
votre émission qui montre qu'on n'est
pas dans les tracés pour le
réchauffement climatique 1,5 degrés et
donc on continue dans nos erreurs on
n'apprend pas de nos erreurs pourquoi
parce que c'est le football business
l'argent qui domine tout ça
votre votre point de vue est-ce qu'il
faut le boycotter
quelques petits éléments de précision
parce que certains sont factuellement
faux d'abord la Coupe du monde elle a
été donnée en 2010 attribuée en 2010 et
pas en 2013 et le chiffre de 6500 morts
c'est pas le chiffre d'amener ces
internationale c'est une enquête de dire
exactement et cette enquête du Guardian
le chiffre sont ne sont pas ceux de
l'Organisation internationale du travail
en
et donc il faut savoir quand on va
ailleurs quand on va chez d'autres
cultures quand on est chez des personnes
qui sont étrangères à la culture à
laquelle on appartient il faut juste
avoir un minimum de mesure et de décence
et de respect même de bon sens par
rapport à des sociétés où ça peut ne pas
être accepté tout ça qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit
universalité des droits humains ont les
filache avec son congrès du sang-mère à
Paris cette semaine avec des militants
des droits humains du monde entier et la
question de l'universalité des droits
humains et donc aussi le respect du
droit à l'orientation sexuelle à ses
choix de libre disposition de son corps
c'est un droit qui est revendiqué par
les personnes qui le vivent et c'est
toujours les chefs d'État qui disent qui
plaident le relativisme en disant notre
culture etc et qui plaide le relativisme
culturel non c'est un une notion très
importante c'est cette universalité des
droits humains qui s'applique à tout
être humain
il y a eu universalité des droits
humains il y a une pétition pardonnée
moyenne pétition qui demande justement à
Emmanuel Macron et au ministre de
boycotter cette Coupe du Monde du Qatar
une pétition qui a été tweeté notamment
par le député européen Raphaël Glucksman
qui est supporter de du PSG depuis 10
ans et qui là qui vient de se rendre
compte que le PSG était détenu par les
catary et qui est plus supporters là il
a annoncé il y a 2 semaines mais bref on
parle de ses morts
parce que l'université évidemment
l'Université des droits humains on peut
pas être contre évidemment il y a aussi
l'Université du du sport et on est un
peu européens c'est-à-dire que si on se
dit demain écoutez on peut organiser que
des Jeux olympiques ou des Coupes du
Monde uniquement dans les pays
démocratiques il y a pas beaucoup de
pays qui vont pouvoir accueillir ces et
au contraire le fait que des pays comme
le Qatar puissent organiser des
événements mondiaux comme ceci ça veut
dire que toute la lumière va être sur
eux donc on va pouvoir voir si vraiment
ce qui se passe au Qatar et ça il faut
que c'est très très important
est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'opinion publique
mondiale n'est pas justement plus
choquée qu'avant de voir ce type
justement d'événements organisé dans des
pays où les droits humains ne sont pas
respectés et où il y a effectivement des
morts sur les chantiers je pense que
c'est l'opinion publique change est-ce
que aujourd'hui la FIFA ferait la même
chose l'opinion publiquementale de la
même manière que l'opinion publique
française et les choqué du 2.2 mesure et
de l'indignation sélective la dynamique
du boycott elle est issue de la Norvège
la Norvège pourtant en 2022 participent
aux JO de Pékin en février alors que
tout le monde sait que une population
minorité ouigo et persécutée voire
génocides elle va Pékin elle ne dit mot
elle elle participe à ses yeux vous
savez pourquoi parce qu'elle a des
grandes chances de cumuler des médailles
et pourquoi la Norvège doux est partie
encore une fois la campagne de boycott
se réveille subitement quand il s'agit
d'un pays dont certains pensent
qu'effectivement c'est parce qu'il est
arabe que certains commencent à se
redécouvrir la question du respect des
droits humains il se taise d'un côté
pour pouvoir s'insurger de l'autre à un
moment donné soit cohérent et on est
dans un boycott non pas sélectif mais
permanent et uniforme soit on ne peut
pas accepter ces deux poids de mesure
parce que comme il a été dit la Coupe du
monde en Russie Emmanuel Macron est
l'ensemble de la société française qui
est rendu il n'y a eu aucune forme de
critique alors que la Crimée avait été
avait été envahi donc on ne peut pas un
moment donné faire comme si les droits
de l'homme ne pouvaient être pris en
compte que lorsqu'un pays arabe et sur
le devant de la scène et qu'on oublie
les situations comme un Pékin et
ailleurs ou on y a été pour pouvoir
cumuler des médailles Alexis de soif
indécent d'une est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'opinion publique mondiale change
justement et plus sensible je pense au
respect des droits humains je crois que
vous avez tout à fait raison il y a une
sensibilité au respect des droits
humains de tout un chacun aussi au
climat la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique les citoyens se mobilisent
sont choqués par les super profits des
grands groupes énergétiques comme total
on a encore parlé aujourd'hui et les
citoyens n'acceptent plus à et demandent
à leur responsable politique
une cohérence et la Coupe du monde elle
aura lieu au Qatar mais est-ce qu'on
entend nos dirigeants demandaient au
Qatar de faire les réformes qui
s'imposent pour faire avancer la cause
ça devrait être l'occasion de faire
avancer la cause des droits humains
c'est la cause du mal c'est la cause de
tout le monde nous on est privilégiés
mais des personnes qui sont atteintes
dans leur droit elle nous demande et
nous avons une responsabilité comme État
tiers de faire progresser les droits
humains de toute personne sur cette
terre et on voit que la FIFA au lieu
d'être cynique comme Infantino le
président devrait demander au Qatar de
faire des progrès de
indemniser les travailleurs mais il ne
le demande pas ils sont bloqués en
disant il faut que ce soit une réussite
sportive parce qu'il y a une histoire de
gros sous qui est lié à ça et c'est tout
ce qui les intéresse qu'ils répondent à
la demande des ONG et que la FIFA
demande des comptes mais Jérôme
est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous dites du
cynisme effectivement de la FIFA dénonce
il est dans son rôle il va pas dire que
ça va être la pire Coupe du Monde qui
est jamais existé ça ça peut pas
justement ces différentes couples aux
différents pays est-ce que alors là je
suis absolument d'accord avec vous c'est
à dire que en 2010 il y a une erreur
fondamentale qui a été faite c'est qu'on
a en fait voté pour deux pays
organisateurs à la suite c'est-à-dire la
Russie en 2018 et le Qatar en 2022 ce
qui a donné lieu en fait à beaucoup de
combinaisons et sans doute de choses en
coulisse dont on n'a pas pris la la
mesure mais c'était une erreur pour Nick
Michel Platini a changé d'avis
a toujours défendu le fait qu'il y a un
pays arabe qui accueille la Coupe du
Monde il avait soutenu le Maroc il a pas
changé d'avis simplement il a toujours
il a été séduit par le projet catharien
et financièrement motivé non ça c'est de
la diffamation
certainement mais ça vous si vous avez
l'épreuve vous le notez mais pour
l'instant
il n'a pas été condamné il y a rien
contre lui simplement ce que ce que je
vais dire c'est que la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar et puis tout ce qu'on tousse qu'on
dit sur Michel Platini qui a changé
d'avis non c'est pas vrai Michel Platini
a toujours dit qu'il voulait
l'université l'universalité du football
et c'est pourquoi il a été séduit à la
fois par le Qatar pour le fait que
jamais un pays arabe auparavant n'avait
accueilli la Coupe du Monde justement
vous qui connaissez bien le Qatar
pourquoi le Qatar se lance-t-il dans une
telle aventure c'est le prestige ça ça
des retombées très fortes dans la région
pour ce cette émirat effectivement
d'organiser la Coupe du monde
aujourd'hui le pourquoi de cette Coupe
du Monde il faut remonter à juin 95 et
l'accession pouvoir de lumière Ahmed Ben
Khalifa c'est-à-dire le père de l'actuel
Emir à l'époque le Qatar est un pays
tout petit isolé sur la scène
internationale non reconnu et donc ce
que va faire les autorités à partir de
Jean 95 c'est de sortir de cet état
d'isolement et de non reconnaissance par
les pas par le système international
afin de se poser sur la carte comme un
carrefour à la fois majeur du sport
international mais également des médias
mais également de la culture afin de
positiver son image parce que les
autorités à l'époque conçoivent que la
prestance le prestige d'un état c'est
autant le nombre de divisions au niveau
militaire mais également la force de son
rayonnement
le soft power que le Qatar va commencer
en 96 avec la chaîne algésira et qu'il
va ensuite enchaîner notamment avec la
question du sport ça remonte à loin
c'est-à-dire dès la fin des années 90 le
Qatar construit un certain nombre
d'infrastructures en 2006 il organise
les Asiatiques alors les Jeux asiatiques
c'est un peu loin pour nous mais c'est
quand même ils vont être organisés en
Arabie Saoudite
et donc les Jeux asiatiques en 2006
c'est quand même le troisième événement
sportif planétaire le plus suivi
d'accord donc après la Coupe du Monde et
les Jeux Olympiques donc on a une vraie
infrastructure des moyens qui sont mis
afin de redorer le blason de cet état
afin d'en faire un acteur majeur au
niveau des perceptions parce que le faut
toujours remettre sa géographie il est
dans un contexte extrêmement volatile
extrêmement périlleux et donc il a
besoin de sortir encore une fois de cet
anonymat pour pouvoir devenir un
exactement pour pouvoir se protéger et
devenir incontournable dans le concert
des nations Alexis de soif mais alors
justement est-ce que ce qui choque
l'opinion ça n'est pas ce décalage entre
ce soft power cette image qui veut se
donner et finalement ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur lorsque vous avez des morts
sur des chantiers et en particulier sur
ces chantiers de construction de Coupe
du Monde est-ce que c'est pas ce
décalage qui choque tout à fait on
instrumentalise le sport à des fins
politiques et à des fins financiers et à
côté de ça il y a énormément de dégâts
au niveau vie humaine au niveau droit
des personnes et on ne profite pas alors
de l'événement sportif pour dire il faut
que ça change il y a et
personne aujourd'hui n'appelle à des
changements ou veut pleinement
contribuer à ces changements moi j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour ces joueurs
de foot australiens qui ont fait passer
ce message là je trouve que toutes les
équipes devraient rivaliser aussi dans
les messages qu'ils envoient avant
d'aller à la Coupe du Monde et la FIFA
finalement elle est un peu aussi un
fossoyeur de passion parce que tous ces
fans de foot et j'en fais partie vont
être tiraillés entre l'envie de regarder
la Coupe du monde que son pays gagne et
puis se dire non on va pas regarder
parce que il y a nos principes éthiques
et toutes ces victimes et les droits
humains et finalement la FIFA elle fait
ça juste pour l'argent juste pour
l'argent
c'est inacceptable comment est-ce qu'on
peut faire ça alors et on ne tire aucune
leçon les événements sportifs futurs les
attributions se font de nouveau en
fonction de ces critères géopolitiques
et financiers
si vous voulez là on est dans la potion
ou c'est difficile de d'être contre
Monsieur parce que évidemment on déroule
tout le bon les bons sentiments etc la
vie humaine qui est précieuse etc mais
il faut pas être manichéen et cette
chose il n'y a pas une vérité absolue
d'un côté et une autre bafouée de
l'autre il faut pas mettre sa tête dans
le sable non plus
vous avez là le voit au chapitre parce
que précisément il y a la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar et vous êtes invité dans toutes
les émissions et vous pouvez et vous
exprimer et ça c'est aussi une chance
comme vous et ben non exactement mais
après moi je suis pas totalement
d'accord avec votre discours donc c'est
un moyen de faire pression aussi
c'est-à-dire que quand le Qatar
accueille la Coupe du Monde il sait très
bien qu'il va accueillir des visiteurs
plein de journalistes des journalistes
qui vont pouvoir voir ce qui se passe
réellement au Qatar et ça c'est bien
parce que si on laissait le Qatar de
côté et nous n'aurons pas accès ce sera
des mises en scène ce sera mais bien sûr
il y a des reportages qui se font en
Qatar ils seront pas dans les camps les
travailleurs ou les travailleurs
pourquoi vous dites ça vous êtes à la
douane vous pensez que les journalistes
pourront librement circuler partout où
ils veulent alors justement on en a une
qui viennent s'installer avec nous qui
est avec nous qui a fait Chloé donad
bonsoir journaliste vous avez réalisé
donc ce reporter le doc qui va passer ce
week-end justement sur le Qatar
Qatar les travailleurs de l'ombre alors
justement quels ont été les conditions
de tournage pour être clair déjà
alors pour ce pour se rendre au Qatar ça
a pas été particulièrement difficile
enfin il faut faire des demandes de de
tournage auprès des autorités qu'on a eu
ce qui a été plus difficile puisque du
coup le le l'idée du documentaire c'est
de raconter la vie de tous ces
travailleurs étrangers qui composent 90%
de la population
qatari ce a été plus difficile c'est de
rencontrer des gens qui acceptent de
vraiment raconter leur histoire parce
que les la voilà la plupart des
travailleurs à qui on a parlé au début
avaient peur soit de perdre leur emploi
soit qu'on annule leur visa et qui
peuvent voilà qui sont obligés de
rentrer dans leur pays donc ça ça a été
compliqué alors vous avez justement
rencontré un travailleur kenyan sur des
chantiers pas vous personnellement mais
votre collègue parce que vous êtes deux
parce que vous étiez une femme donc vous
n'aviez pas accès à ces chantiers c'est
ça et on va regarder un extrait
voilà comment on vit au Qatar à Doha
ça sent mauvais
ici est un enfer
personne ne doit savoir que je fais ça
au Qatar publié des images négatives du
pays et passibles d'expulsion
c'est quand sont interdits d'accès aux
journalistes mais excédé par leurs
conditions de vie
Ibrahim et ses compagnons de chambrer
prennent le risque de nous faire entrer
avec une caméra
depuis les premiers jours ces ouvriers
ont nettoyé eux-mêmes ce qu'ils
pouvaient mais il manque encore de tout
voilà c'est notre logement
c'est regarder venez à l'intérieur
la nuit il y a des gens qui dorment par
terre on fait comme ça
pourquoi il nous laisse là
l'entreprise avait dit qu'elle nous
donnerait des lits qu'elle nous
donnerait à manger
mais ici pas de cantine ni de frigo ni
même un endroit pour cuisiner
voilà comment on prépare à manger
on essaie juste de survivre
regardez ça c'est ce qu'on achète on ne
nous donne pas de repas c'est ça qu'on
mange
ce qui nous arrive on n'en peut plus
on est fatigué voilà c'est tout
en plus de ce logement insalubre ces
travailleurs affirment ne pas avoir été
payé depuis des mois
tous les jours ils disent qu'on va
toucher notre salaire mais il ne donne
rien
ça fait presque un an et il n'y a pas
que moi tous mes amis aussi
on a essayé d'en parler à l'employeur
mais il a menacé d'appeler la police
sans mon certains veulent rentrer dans
leur pays d'autres voudraient changer
d'entreprise mais l'employeur a
confisqué nos passeports
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
c'est de l'esclavage c'est comme une
prison
c'est une violation des droits de
l'homme ce n'est pas juste
ce n'est pas juste de vivre comme ça
allez faut y aller
comme Ibrahim plus de 2,5 millions
d’étrangers vivent et travaillent au
Qatar
voilà ce sont ces étrangers donc enfin
celui-là en particulier travaillait
aussi sur les chantiers Chloé il a
travaillé sur les chantiers en fait il
est arrivé au Qatar en 2020 la société
katarienne pour laquelle il travaille là
d'abord mis sur des chantiers de
construction et ensuite la voilà la
changer de poste il a ensuite travaillé
dans dans un centre commercial où il
remplissait les courses des clients on
peut dire que c'est de l'esclavage
moderne Nabil et Nasri votre réaction
alors la situation effectivement au
Qatar jusqu'à aujourd'hui il s'agissant
des ouvriers reste déplorables pour une
grande partie évidemment d'entre
maintenant ce qu'il faut redire c'est
que s'agissant des chantiers de la Coupe
du monde ça n'a jamais été plus de 2 à
3% du nombre total d'ouvriers au Qatar
qui ont été employés ces 10 dernières
années c'est à dire au plus fort de la
construction entre 2014 et 2018 on était
aux alentours de 25 à 30000 ouvriers ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que c'est aussi le
jour et la nuit entre la situation des
ouvriers en 2010 et aujourd'hui à tel
point que l'association et l'ONG faire
square project dit que la situation des
droits de l'homme au Qatar est
aujourd'hui la plus avancée des
monarchies du Golfe ceci étant ceci
étant c'est grâce naturellement à la
pression internationale c'est grâce à la
pression internationale que ces efforts
ont été consentis par exemple
l'abolition de la kafala la
kafalajeux qui maintenait l'ouvrier sous
une dépendance par rapport à son
employeur a été démantelée ces dernières
années jusqu'à totalement abolie il y a
quelques mois alors ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'encore une fois il y a énormément de
choses et de chemin à parcourir par
contre on ne peut pas nier les efforts
qui ont été consentis et qui ont été
salués par même amenésie international
est-ce qu'il y a eu des efforts alors
j'ai vu effectivement que en tout cas le
Qatar a démantelé ce fameux kafala ce
système de tutelle du droit musulman
mais bon le reportage de Chloé Aqua 3
mois donc on voit que ça c'est une
situation d'aujourd'hui
et il faut quand même rappeler que ils
n'ont pas le droit de se syndiquer parce
que créer un syndicat c'est
donc et donc c'est interdit donc ils ne
peuvent pas associé ils ne peuvent pas
se syndiquer c'est un droit fondamental
c'est la Déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme et donc leurs droits
sont bafoués on reste sans voix après un
reportage comme celui-là et on ne
comprend pas comment parmi les 14
grosses sponsors de la Coupe du Monde
seulement 4 ont dénié réponse aux ONG
qui les ont interpellés pour créer un
fond d'indemnisation des victimes des
chantiers parce que les chantiers c'est
pas que les stades c'est les routes
c'est toute la construction
l'infrastructure qui a été faite c'était
gigantesque un projet gigantesque au
détriment des travailleurs alors
justement je reviens ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est précisément parce
qu'on a donné l'organisation de la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar qu'on peut avoir ce
genre de reportage et voir vraiment les
conditions parce qu'il y a des
journalistes qui s'y intéressent
maintenant vous savez ils ont pas eu
libre accès
est-ce qu'on le découvre aujourd'hui
ne savait même pas le situer sur la
carte maintenant dans deux ans il y a
des Jeux Olympiques à Paris je vous dis
moi avec une caméra je vais parler de la
chapelle je fais les mêmes images
apocalyptiques et puis je je décide un
dessin crépusculaire donc ce sera de
fake news après vous ah c'est pas news
mais c'est pas des fake news qui se
passe à la Porte de la Chapelle un jeu
de pierre du Stade de France ou aura
lieu
les ouvriers des stades c'est d'accord
il y a la machine il y a des problèmes
quel qu'il soit donc il y a une
délégation de la fidège qui a des reçus
par le président Macron maintenant il y
a effectivement une série de demandes
qui sont adressées au Président pour la
des violations de droits humains en
France voilà donc c'est bien aussi de
s'occuper aujourd'hui on parle du Qatar
et et on peut parler des droits humains
après avoir justement fait cette enquête
sur place
moi je pense que effectivement le fait
que la Coupe du Monde se tienne au Qatar
ça ça met un coup de projecteur sur ce
pays ça met la pression sur les
autorités cathariennes qui ont été qui
ont fait des réformes qui des
importances évidemment le travailleur
que vous avez filmé non mais ces
réformes le travailleur par ailleurs il
ne nie pas que les réformes existent le
problème c'est que ces réformes elles
existent sur le papier et elles sont
encore peu mise en oeuvre sur le terrain
c'est en fait c'est
en application c'est le manque
d'inspecteur du travail aujourd'hui qui
fait que l'effectivité dans la réalité
des réformes adoptées en lieu ne sont
pas encore largement mises en
application
pour le it bon beaucoup plus ça on parle
des milliers de morts pour l'enquête du
gardien vous êtes intéressés à ça
également Chloé c'est c'est difficile
vraiment de donner un chiffre réel les
alors moi j'ai pas fait mon enquête
personnelle pour pour savoir vraiment
combien de personnes sont mortes
probablement que que beaucoup sont
mortes
c'est voilà c'est un sujet qui est assez
compliqué
et ce sont des milliers de morts parce
que vous avez jamais vu pour
l'organisation d'une Coupe du Monde
c'est des milliers de morts alors les
raisons c'est les conditions de travail
des horaires impossibles dans des
conditions de travail extrêmement
chaudes parce qu'il y avait pas que 25
degrés en décembre en été c'est 50
degrés on travaille
et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont climatisé
leur stade si la température est idéale
pour jouer au football c'est vraiment
mettre sa tête dans le sable c'est nier
l'évidence ils ont climatisé leur stade
qui est un non-sens écologique et les
stades ont été construits en été compris
avec des conditions de travail mais
inhumaines il est mort je repose la
question c'était il y a 12 ans vous
dites on ne connaissait pas le Qatar à
l'époque est-ce que la FIFA la FIFA
ferait la même chose aujourd'hui écoutez
bien alors évidemment mais la FIFA
ferait la même chose sans doute pas
parce que avec toute la polémique il y a
jamais une coupe du monde qui n'a fait
couler autant d'encre donc ça veut dire
qu'elle pourrait changer
l'opinion publique est contre nous vous
voyez enfin il y a une doxa dominante
tout ce contrôle Qatar etc mais si vous
voulez si les stades sont climatisés
c'est parce que on veut pas justement en
faire des éléphants en blanc et on veut
que les stades puissent aussi être utile
pour les périodes d'été etc quand même
un non sens environnemental on peut pas
on peut pas le nier non mais la
climatisation va pas fonctionner
uniquement pour la Coupe du Monde
ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'encore
est une mort évidemment de trop
maintenant il faut faire attention à
ceux qui vont utiliser et
instrumentaliser le sort des ouvriers au
Qatar maltraités pour pouvoir régler
leurs différents géopolitiques avec ce
pays il faut faire très attention à
celles et ceux qui utilisent et qui
instrumentalise parce que pour aller
pourrai vous répondre un tout petit peu
moi j'aurais beaucoup de respect pour
les joueurs australiens si parce que
c'est un peu des indignés du mois
d'octobre si s'indignait aujourd'hui de
la Coupe du monde en 2026 aux États-Unis
pour deux raisons parce tous les coups
écologiques sera beaucoup plus important
pour cette Coupe du Monde 2026 qui va se
jouer sur trois pays dont deux
continents avec en plus 48 équipes donc
beaucoup plus de déplacements et de vols
entre entre les capitales en tout cas
entre les villes hautes et puis en plus
la question des droits des États-Unis
c'est quand même la peine de mort c'est
que moi voilà
pour savoir si les États-Unis ne sont
pas responsables de leur malheur ce sont
des centaines de milliers de morts c'est
là par contre est-ce qu'on va voir des
équipes Chloé
pour les défendre jusqu'au bout soit on
fait pas d'indignation sélective alors
Chloé daumat vous allez revenir
également sur on va regarder à notre
extrait de votre de votre reportage
puisque effectivement vous avez aussi
suivi cette entrepreneuse indienne et
pour elle c'est l'Eldorado le Qatar
c'est intéressant de le regarder pour
voir justement son point de vue voir en
fait ce qu'elle a pu faire des
conditions de ces conditions économiques
et en même temps les limites bien sûr
qui sont liées au système on va regarder
un extrait
bonjour tout le monde j'espère que le
mois va bien se passer dans la joie et
la bonne humeur et surtout qu'on fasse
des affaires
le mois dernier vous avez bien travaillé
je suis contente c'est très bien
continuez comme ça
a commencé il y a 22 ans comme
simplement deux
aujourd'hui elle dirige 14 personnes
tous viennent du sous-continent indien
et touche environ 10 fois plus que dans
leur pays
mais ils ont intérêt à le mériter
alors ragens quel est ton objectif ce
mois-ci
15000 ce n'est pas assez pour toi
non plus 15000 ce n'est pas assez assez
focus tu viens de rentrer de vacances
et toi
c'est mon gagne pas c'est tout pour moi
ma maison mon bureau tout est à doigt
c'est pour ça que vous êtes venu au
Qatar bien sûr
et dieu soit loué le Qatar m'a tout
donné
chaque mois farsanna reçoit une dizaine
de CV de nouveau candidats à
l'immigration
pour ces Indiens le Qatar représente une
sorte d'eldorado
je suis venu car je pense que le Qatar
est un endroit excitant où il y a
beaucoup d'opportunités
pour gagner de l'argent ou acquérir de
l'expérience c'est pour ça qu'on vient
ici
ok allez vous pouvez retourner
travailler merci beaucoup
les gens à l'étranger meurent d'envie de
venir ici ils ont l'impression que des
lingots d'or poussent sur les arbres
qu'ils vont venir et que ça sera facile
mais ce n'est pas si simple la réussite
c'est de la sueur et des larmes
réussir à Doha à un prix
la loi oblige par Zana à être parrainé
par un qatarien
ce système qui maintient les étrangers
sous tutelle s'appelle la kafala
si vous n'êtes pas catharien comme moi
qui viens d'Inde et que vous voulez
monter une entreprise il faut avoir un
associé local c'est associé prend 51%
des parts et c'est lui qui possède la
société et il prend 51% du profit non
non
comment ça marche
le sponsor prend quelque chose chaque
mois c'est-à-dire on fixe une somme de
combien il touche chaque mois
on doit accepter ses conditions vous
savez il faut savoir faire des
concessions et se plier en quatre pour
avancer en affaires il faut se montrer
flexible
je ne peux pas être trop exigeante parce
qu'en fin de compte c'est leur pays
[Musique]
autre point de vue donc Chloé assez
intéressant on voit ses contraintes
alors on a parlé justement elle parle de
la kafala c'était il y a trois mois
est-ce que ça a changé un peu justement
on en parlait de dans son cas ça n'a pas
changé
d'avoir un sponsor catharien qui détient
51 % des parts de son entreprise et en
même temps elle voit on voit une sorte
d'eldorado
l'arbre qui pousse l'argent qui pousse
aux arbres
eldorado pour certains au détriment
d'autres qui sont exploités dans des
conditions absolument indignes oui mais
je pense que c'est important de
souligner que
c'est un pays où 90% de la population
est composée de de travailleurs
étrangers et ils ne vivent pas tous dans
des conditions proches de l'esclavage
moderne il y a des gens pour qui le
Qatar
offre des opportunités il y a des gens
qui viennent chercher une vie meilleure
au Qatar et qui trouve une vie meilleure
au Qatar et qui sont heureux d'y vivre
et d'y travailler
alors pour terminer puisqu'il nous reste
un peu plus de 5 minutes est-ce que le
monde du sport devrait être plus
soucieux des droits humains dans
l'attribution d'un tournoi oui je pense
et je pense aussi que c'est par respect
pour finalement ceux qui font vivre
celles et ceux qui font vivre le sport
c'est ceux qui le regardent parce que on
est tous mal à l'aise par rapport à ça
et donc on devrait le sport et la devise
olympique c'est vraiment pour rassembler
les peuples autour de cette passion
commune du sport et donc par respect
pour tous ces gens là abandonnés le seul
critère d'argent et en profiter pour
dire ben voilà on veut améliorer rendre
ce monde plus juste et peut-être que par
le biais du sport et qui a une
responsabilité partagée des États tiers
des chefs d'État des responsables
politiques mais aussi des joueurs ou des
sportifs qui peuvent dire mais moi je
n'ai pas envie de par exemple voyager en
jet privé pour aller faire un
déplacement de 200 km j'ai plutôt envie
de prendre le train ils font partie de
cette société ils en vivent bien et très
bien ils ont une responsabilité accrue
alors est-ce que c'est à chacun de
choisir où est-ce qu'effectivement il
faudrait qu'il y ait des critères au
sein donc de la FIFA qui disent voilà il
y a certains seuil endroits humains dans
son seuil c'est l'environnement il faut
c'est l'appliquer mais c'est l'appliquer
je suis désolé sur les appliquer de
manière générale et uniforme Paris Jo
2024 excusez-moi le monde arabe ou même
une grande partie de ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur des salons parisiens vous
dire mais à qui la France vend des armes
vous donnez des leçons de morale à
certains nombre de pays dans ce pays en
train de montrer une affiche c'est très
bien c'est très bien mais en matière de
respect des droits humains je peux vous
dire à l’épods la population civile à
certains de pays où en Égypte et
ailleurs pour voir quel est
l'effectivité pas du tout
ce que je n'ai pas dit il faut faire
comme Amnesty International c'est-à-dire
faire pression sur ce genre de pays pour
pouvoir arracher un certain nombre
d'avantages de réformes et c'est
exactement cette posture qui est la plus
intelligente et la police
on est bien seul qui permet d'avancer
qui est la seule en mesure de ne pas
alors aussi avec nous faire pression
pourquoi est-ce que c'est Amnesty là et
fidelh les organes white watch les
organisations défense des droits humains
évidemment il faut se trouve de la même
manière que j'ajouterai un deuxième
critère la question de la sobriété
énergétique là aussi c'est un ensemble
la Coupe du Monde 2026 on ne peut pas
continuer avec des organisations comme
ça ou ce sont des centaines de vols et
des milliers de personnes des centaines
de micro va déplacer alors que comme
vous l'avez montré juste avant on est au
bord du précipice
réformer
qui est quand même connu quand même pour
son manque de courage qui va pas changer
le le cours le cours des choses
maintenant moi ce que je vous dis et
là-dessus je le rejoindre un petit peu
c'est que la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
c'est vrai qu'on en a dit pique pendre
mais vous allez voir qu'au niveau
football est faite parce que vous posiez
cette question est-ce que ça va être une
fête moi je pense que oui parce que ça
arrive en plein milieu la saison les
joueurs vont être en forme les
conditions climatiques vont être bonnes
et vous allez voir vos spectacles et les
gens vont regarder la Coupe du monde et
vous verrez il y aura des records
d'audience est-ce qu'il justement au
niveau diplomatique que ça soit plus
limité pas de représentation la
effectivement il y a une pétition qui
demande à Emmanuel Macron de ne pas s'y
rendre que les ministres n'y seront pas
est-ce qu'il y aurait cette possibilité
par exemple pour manifester il faut
boycotter la fête en disant on en voit
pas les chefs d'État de haut niveau on
envoie éventuellement une délégation de
second couteau parce que on va pas leur
faire ce plaisir-là en plus et quand
vous sauté
à Moscou personne n'a rien dit on l'a
dénoncé
mais justement il va pas faire la même
chose au kata et la fête ne va pas être
totale le nombre de communes de ville et
de village qui ont décidé de ne pas
mettre de grand écran donc la fête elle
est déjà un peu gâchée elle est déjà un
peu elle est déjà un peu gâchée et en
fait ça va être la Coupe du Monde de la
honte et les pays qui vont la gagner ou
le pays qui va la gagner ben elle aura
gagné franchement démagogique Macron va
se rendre juste après pour pouvoir
courtiser le Qatar pour pouvoir
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
politique qui consiste permettre entre
parenthèses un pays et le courtiser
avant et lui faire la courte échelle
après soit on est cohérent et on le
boycott sur les armes et sur la question
on va et on participe et comme un style
de monde on fait pression et on utilise
justement le levier propose de créer un
fond justement d'indemnisation des
familles des ouvriers peut-être vous
pouvez en dire un mot Chloé oui oui
demande de depuis un certain temps
maintenant qu'il y a un qu'un fond soit
créé par par la FIFA afin d'indemniser
les les ouvriers qui qui ont été blessés
et leur famille dans voilà dans les cas
où il y a eu des candidats
favorablement à ce genre de demande
pourquoi
exprimés il y a un responsable qui a
commencé effectivement dire que c'est
une idée qu'il fallait effectivement à
laquelle on est en train de réfléchir
donc il faut continuer évidemment cette
pression populaire médiatique citoyenne
pour forcer la FIFA à mettre en place
effectivement ce fonds de compensation
de compensation et que on puisse
interpeller encore une fois ces grandes
organisations pour qu'elles se
renouvelle à la fois pour une
application et pour ce critère des
droits humains qui soient transversales
et uniformes mais également encore une
fois j'insiste pour avoir davantage de
sobriété énergétiques la Coupe du Monde
2026 c'est vraiment la folie en terme
climatique après pourquoi est-ce que la
FIFA ne fait pas plus ensemble sur la
sobriété pour son image mais pour son
argent mais c'est normal c'est à dire
c'est la FIFA organise la Coupe du monde
donc évidemment faute business
évidemment et ça moi je le condamne
également mais maintenant afin de Tino
entre guillemets bon c'est vrai qu'il
est transparent et c'est pas lui qui
c'est pas lui qui va changer le cours de
l'histoire comme je l'ai dit
malheureusement et c'est vrai qu'il
faudrait une voix peut-être un
personnage plus charismatique une voix
qui porte davantage qu'avantino pour
qu'il y ait au moins de de l'écho
maintenant il aura l'opposition
peut-être de pays qui
pourra revenir au CO2 à la taxe carbone
etc la Coupe du Monde au locataire vous
pourrez voir dans le même lieu trois
quasiment trois matchs on essaie la
en 2026 il y aura trois pays il faudra
faire 4000 km pour voir plusieurs matchs
en avion je parle donc il faut comparer
aussi les choses il faut être juste
équanime parce qu'autrement bon c'est
vrai on peut s'en prendre au kata parce
que c'est un petit pays et puis on va
pas toucher aux États-Unis ni à la
Russie parce que attention ils peuvent
vous montrer plus de muscle 1,2 à 1,4
millions de personnes qui vont aller au
Qatar ils sont prêts franchement ben
c'est oui oui toutes les enfin il y a un
certain nombre d'infrastructures qui le
sont pas encore mais c'est vrai que
c'est colossal pour un petit pays à
peine plus grand que la Corse et qui a 3
millions d'habitants c'est comme si en
France un espace d'un mois vous avez 35
millions de touristes qui débarquaient
en l'espace de quelques semaines donc
un vrai défi logistique mais le problème
c'est qu'en 2010 c'était au tour de
l'Asie et l'Asie avait non seulement pas
beaucoup de prétendants et que en même
temps il était destiné dans le sens de
l'histoire de donner au monde arabe
cette Coupe du monde le pays qu'il avait
demandé précédemment mais qui n'était
pas candidat en 2010 c'était le Maroc et
donc il restait le Qatar et donc à un
moment donné il fallait évidemment
permettre cette aire d'accueillir un
événement pour conclure oui non moi
c'était sur la sur la question du boycot
je pense qu'effectivement les aspects
climatiques la question des droits de
l'homme c'est des choses qui sont qui
sont fondamentales mais c'est un peu
tard en fait je pense que c'est des
questions qu'il fallait se poser il y a
10 ans quand on a décidé de d'organiser
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar et dans ce
sens-là on peut reprocher beaucoup de
choses au Qatar mais il y a une
responsabilité collective
que voilà qu'on peut qu'on peut pas
ignorer et c'est un peu tard pour pour
se poser ces questions merci Chloé
daumat donc votre
documentaire reporter qui va donc être
diffusé ce week-end à partir de samedi
sur France 24 qui est dans le titre est
travailleur de l'ombre voilà les
travailleurs de l'ombre et vous l'avez
réalisé avec rampe patteria merci en
tout cas d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci Alexis de soif merci Nabil et
Nasri Merci à VOUS Jérôme Gessel et
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
sur France 24